chris can you stop staring your screen
for the mail please
chairman we're live
good evening good afternoon sorry ladies
and gentlemen or even good morning
in fact let's get it right uh good
morning ladies and gentlemen
welcome to strap district council's
annual council meeting
um if i can just start off with
uh the normal etiquettes that we have
been used to hearing before
meetings um you're all aware
of them but i'd like to reiterate the
following points
can you make sure that your device is
fully charged or is charging
uh please mute your microphones when not
speaking
please indicate in the chat bar if you
wish to speak
and that will be monitored by officers
to ensure that nobody has missed out
when invited to address the council for
clarification please
state your name ensure the microphone is
switched on
and switched off immediately after
you've finished
please ensure you have switched off or
on silent any other devices
that you have that may interrupt
proceedings
if any member wishes to speak on an item
please as i've already said indicate
that through chat
if any member encounters itd problems
causing them drop out of the virtual
meeting they should use best endeavors
to rejoin as quickly as possible
should the meeting member be unable to
rejoin the meeting
they'll be deemed to have left the
meeting at that point and the meeting
will continue numbers to call should you
experience
any it problems are
either the it help desk on one seven
eight nine two six
zero zero two zero or caroline nash
our democratic services manager on
seven six four one six
three five three please the
meeting has been broadcast live
most importantly if required
whilst any secret ballot is taking place
the slide will be displayed on the
website
informing members of the public that the
meeting will resume
shortly please remember a live
team meeting cannot be adjourned so
anything you say
during that period will be
heard in public
members the chief executive will now ask
each member to confirm by way of a role
call
their name and they can see and hear
this i'll start off with hurtful i can
see and hear the proceedings
okay thank you councillor uh okay
vice chairman of council councillor
dixon please repeat the name
councillor dixon can hear and see thank
you very much
before we proceed can i please make sure
that everybody who's not speaking has
their microphones muted please
it's going to make it impossible
otherwise um counselor lewis adam
councillor lewis adam i can see in here
the proceedings thank you
thank you we have apologies from
councillor victoria alcock
uh councillor joe barker
i can see and hear proceedings
councillor joe barker
thank you uh councillor tony grummage i
can see and hear proceedings perfectly
fine thank you
thank you if you could just repeat your
name at the beginning when you speak as
well yeah
fantastic thank you um custom cargill
mark cargill i can see in here
proceedings thank you
thank you councillor jill cleve
councillor jill cleave i can see and
hear proceedings
thank you councillor andy crump
councillor andy crum
i can hear and see the proceedings thank
you thank you
thank councillor david curtis council
david curtis yes i can hear and see
very well thank you thank you councillor
eden
councillored and i can see him here
proceedings thank you
thank you councillor fielding councillor
fielding i can hear and see everything
thank you councillor fitter
council of fitter i can see in here
[Music]
clicking council chambers is is very
important that those in the chamber
again move their microphones thank you
councillor foytec
count the voice i can see in here
proceedings thank you
thank you uh councillor foreman
councillor jill forman i can see and
hear the proceedings
thank you very much jill um counselor
ian fragili
counsel here and frankly i can see and
hear proceedings
thank you very much uh councillor jenny
fragili councillor journey fragility i
can see
and hear proceedings thank you
councillor jackie harris
councillor harris have you ever used a
microphone
trevor harvey there
thank you i can i can see
proceedings i am having great difficulty
in hearing proceedings because there is
i mean
yes i'm here okay thank you very much
casper
harvey uh councillor peter hincher
seraphine
councillor henshaw seraphine i can see
and hear the proceedings
thank you councillor jefferson
county sir tony jefferson i can see and
hear the proceedings
thank you councillor jennings
councillor jennings here i can hear and
see your proceedings
thank you castle juneed councillor do
you know susan's unite here i can hear
and see all the proceedings
here we have a policies from council
kendall so council of mills
council meals i can hear and see all
proceedings
thank you thank you councillor o'donnell
councillor penny anna o'donnell i can
see and hear all proceedings
thank you councillor parry councillor
anne parry i can
see and hear all the proceedings thank
you thank you
uh councillor pemberton
council of pemberton i can see and hear
the proceedings uh chief executive i
think we've skipped past councillor
fleming
apologies castle bill fleming probably
cast the bill flaring i can see and hear
the proceedings i was going to wait till
the end anyway
apologies for that fleming i'm
councillor patella
councilor manuela pertagella i can see
and hear the proceedings
thank you councillor richards
councillor richards i can see and hear
all proceedings
thank you uh council of riley councillor
john riley i can see and hear the
proceedings
thanks thank you good to see councillor
nigel rock back
up councillor nigel rock
i can see and hear the proceedings
thank you casper wolf councillor kate
rolfe i can see
and hear proceedings thank you
councillor shinton
dancer shenton i can see and hear the
proceedings
thank you very much i'm councillor wally
hoggins
councillor warley hoggins i can see and
hear proceedings
thank you chairman
chairman i think we've moved prayers
thank you um
i will now invite our my chaplain um
for the last time uh today uh to open
the meeting with
with perez uh nikki
i'd like to just start by thanking
everybody for allowing me
the last two years to come and be your
chaplain or at least be the chairman's
chaplain
it's actually given me quite an insight
into how the council works
and actually things that i should have
already known so thank you
god we pray for all leaders across the
world
we pray for those in national and local
government
those here in the council and those
on zoom entrusted with representing the
interests and needs of the people they
serve
taking decisions which directly
influence our lives
wrestling with limited resources and
numerous demands
give them the qualities they need to
serve faithfully
truly serving the needs of the people in
our communities
give them the qualities they need to
answer their people's problems
give them courage wisdom guidance good
judgment
and all that they need to hold office
lord in your mercy
hear our prayer living god we
can lose sight sometimes of the unsung
work
so many do behind the scenes of the
invaluable contributions made to society
by those
who are in untram triumphed walks of
life
too easily we can overlook faithful
service offered in silence
we thank you for all those that work
in our council offices for all those who
run and work in our council services
remind us that jesus came to serve
rather than to be served
and grant us all the humility to do the
same
lord in your mercy hear our prayer
at this time when our media and our
minds are still
so often full of news about coronavirus
we pray for all those who've been all
those who have been touched
personally by it those who have been ill
as a result of it
those who have died and those who live
in the pain of their loss
it help us to remember that for many of
people across the world
local and national and international
this is yet another peril to add to
their fragile life
we pray for those whose life is
routinely full of difficulties perils
and danger
the poor the hungry the homeless the
unemployed
the weak the vulnerable oppressed lonely
unwanted sorrowful
lord we ask you to lift them up
and help us to recognize them in our own
communities
give us eyes to see them ears to hear
what they need to it have improved in
their life
wisdom and guidance to know what to do
to help them
give us the heart and strength to be
their advocate
lord in your mercy hear our prayer
gracious god we pray for all those who
have offered their services to their
their communities those who have taken
on new positions of responsibility
equip them to fulfill their duties
wisely and faithfully
those undertaking long-term projects
give them renewed inspiration and vigor
in their work
those who are now standing down or who
have stood down
from positions of office may they know
their labors have been
appreciated and find new ways to be
serve both locally
and through family and friends
help us all to follow their example and
not only to call for change
but to work for it to play our part
before
we ask others to play theirs merciful
father
accept these prayers for the sake of
your son
our savior jesus christ amen
thank you again nikki for those very
helpful
the chairman seems to be frozen
thank you council we'll just resolve
this issue um
kettle are you there
for one second it seems that counselor
careful is frozen um
i will walk back for your tolerance on
this at the moment i apologize
right hello everybody i'm sorry about
that slight
intermission um i shall start where i
left off
um it's my for the regret that i have to
inform you
or the death of a former leader of this
council uh councillor bob stevens who
was district councillor for the southern
ward
in 1992-1996 and the long itchington
ward
99-2011 council stevens also served as a
warwickshire county councillor
the southern division from 97 to 2005
the felden division in 2005 until
his passing he was actually in office
when he died
and as one of his members of his
division i confirmed he was uh
working right up to his very unexpected
demise the council extends its sympathy
to his family and friends
um noting that um there will be a more
formal tribute given at the next full
council meeting which will be on 19th
october 2020
it now falls on me to invite um
nominations for the chairman of the
council
for the period 2021
had one nomination which uh that is i'm
very delighted to nominate my successor
from tony dixon and i'm looking forward
to a seconder and i'm informed
that um the secondary will be
uh council official are there any other
nominations
for the host of chairman
thank you there are no other nominations
for the position of chairman of the
council
and therefore i'm delighted to
hand over the reigns of this role to
councillor dixon
and we will have a short intermission
whilst we actually move from one side of
the room to the other
um obviously those of you attended a
previous handover sherman it's
a little bit easy to do when you're
doing face space
uh councillor dixon you've got kind of
like to take the take the chat
oh god
um
good morning everybody this is uh
capsular tony dixon i'm now ready to
make my declaration of acceptance of
office
i tony dixon having been elected to the
office of chairman of the council
of the district of stratford-upon-avon
here
i declare that i take that office upon
myself and will duly and faithfully
fulfill the duties
of it according to the best of my
judgment and ability
i undertake to be guided by the
stratford-upon-avon district council's
code of members
conduct in the performance of my
functions in that office
and i will now sign that declaration
before we move through to agenda item
two
i would just like to address the council
first my thanks to all members for
asking me to once again be your chairman
and to represent the council across the
whole district it will be a privilege
one of the many things which i learned
last time was that our society is
reliant
upon the many volunteers who day in and
day out
give of their time never wishing to
receive but always prepared to give
during this regrettable pandemic many
have again given of their time
i want nothing in exchange on behalf of
the council
i thank them and if the current
restrictions are sufficiently relaxed
to enable the various luncheon clubs for
the elderly or disabled to return
then i asked my fellow councillors to
please inform me
of any in their awards as i wish to
visit
as many of these luncheon clubs as
possible to give my personal thanks to
the volunteers
my only nerves would is sorely missed by
the 40 or so regulars
who were able to attend until march
prior to the arrival of the virus i had
designed decided
to join the sponsored walk being
arranged by the shakespeare hospice to
celebrate their 21st birthday
it should have been in may was postponed
until this month
but has had to be postponed a second
time into the new year
and although a date has yet to be fixed
i hope it will be before my
turn ends next may i am selecting the
shakespeare's hospice as my chairman's
charity
last time when i was your chairman my
mother was my consult
when she died in 2018 the last two
people to see her
with me were two ladies from the hospice
at home service
they were wonderful hence my decision to
select that hospice
as my in addition to a charity walk
it is my intention to try and walk from
the globe theater back to stratford
along the shakespeare way
about 130 miles ideally to time such a
walk
to arrive back in stratford on the day
that the theater reopens
we all know that will not be before the
new year and trust it will be not
too long into the new year before we can
again see productions
in our theater if any member wishes to
join me on the walk
which will be no less than nine days
just let me know
if not the whole walk then perhaps one
of the two days after i
cross the border into our district near
the roll right stones
south of london finally
whilst the government have imposed new
restrictions
i am pleased that they have made an
exception to enable
organized health walks to continue so
objective guidelines and a maximum of 30
and not
just six when i was your chairman in
2005-2006
together with my mother we walked
several times with
uk it was my chosen charity and if such
walks are being planned again
during these covert 19 issues then
please let me know
i will be very happy to once again walk
with those wishing to maintain their
health
turning now to agenda item 2.
there has only been one other councillor
who served the council
for a second term and that was the late
sir william lawrence
no counselor has previously done two
terms in succession
together with an extension of service i
know
that i'm following a hard act i'm sure
that councillor kettle will relate
some of the highlights of his term in a
few moments
but for myself i simply say chris many
thanks for your commitment
to service i now move
that the council offers its sincere
congratulations
and thanks to councillor kettle for the
exemplary manner
in which she carried out the duties of
the chairman of the council
in the years 2018 19 20 19
20. and i will present councillor kettle
with his past germans badge and some
flowers
for his consult his wife
councillor kettle is now
out of the council chamber so
essentially uh the presentation of
the chairman's past badge and the
flowers will take place
after the meeting
we now move to the election of a vice
chairman
of the council and beggar pardon uh
councillor kettle
to address the council please
thank you mr chairman um
[Music]
firstly uh thank you for those kind
words
i would like to start off by thanking
all those
who have helped me over the past two and
a half years
and i'll start off with claire johnson
my pa
without clear support and guidance as
claire knows only too well
many of these things that i've managed
to do would not have happened and of
course
in claire's absence not forgetting tina
as well so thank thank you claire antina
for guiding me through
what a challenging uh footpath that i've
had to follow
even if it hasn't been from london down
the shakespeare way
i'd also like to thank david buckland
for the support he's given me over the
past two and a half years
and um nikki my chaplain
who signed on for a year two and a half
years ago
um and very willingly has continued uh
time and again to support this council
in opening our sessions with
um the prayers that we have heard on
many occasions
which quite clearly she has prepared
especially for us
um on each occasion so thank you nikki
very much and i'm glad she's in the room
with me to be able to hear those
[Music]
thanks
i'd also like to thank you my fellow
councillors for the support you've given
me
over that time um notwithstanding that
um sometimes i had a little bit of
challenge with your names and
hoichik did remind me after the last
full council meeting i chaired that
there is an opportunity
um to get his name right um
jason thank you for being so forbearing
to allow me to mispronounce your name
over all those years and i apologize
i would also like to thank all the
officers we have been through
an extraordinary time over the last six
months and i know you've been thanked
before
and quite rightly because what you have
done
is keep this council and the services we
provide
to members of this district the electors
um giving them the support they needed
they needed that support and without
your continuing commitment to provide it
this district would have been a very
much worse state than it is
so thank you my fellow colleagues
and officers for that so the story
started for me
when the former councillor george
accident norma to me has nominated me as
his vice chairman
my first full council meeting was a
little bit of a challenge because we had
two people wanting to be leader
former council chris saint and our
current leader tony
um and i'm delighted to say that tony
has now been chair for two and a half
years
um and um it was just a very interesting
start and i think a unique one according
to mr buckland our monitoring officer
um i've worked with three heads of
service i started with dave webb
uh he was followed by isabella
and then as i think i referred to it
david's resignation
young david mr buckland who is now our
head of service
thank you all three of you um you've
made my life
easier it's a strange role and i did not
expect
part of it to have to continually
announce the death of
what is now seven former or current
councillors
five of whom were chairmen two sitting
councillors and attend their funerals
15 months ago of course the council's
name without warning appeared on the
front pages and national newspapers
following
leaked uh facebook allegations by a
former senior officer
it was uncomfortable time for all of us
some more than others
we have recovered from that and
thankfully
we have moved on and now we have a
pandemic
probably the most serious risk to our
district's future
that will ever i hope have to face along
with the worry and uncertainty that that
has brought
then of course there is the upside one
of the first events i attended
was a midlands wide sports
mini world games at warwick university
and the joy of seeing a primary school
from tamworth
our current chairman's ward attending
and taking part in a whole series of
games many of which i was very delighted
i hadn't had to
take part in when i was at primary
school um
and the delight on their faces when i um
announced to them that as the only team
from stratfor district
they were representatives the whole
district
was really it was a great moment the
enthusiasm of the side-by-side
production by the educationally
challenged children
the fantastic array of orchestral and
choral music across the district
and the productions not only in our
flagship from our shakespeare company
theaters
but also the other theaters
uh the bear pit and the second thoughts
uh production
and other sites across the district is
all there
we are a center of cultural excellence
what i didn't know before i became
chairman that some of this exists and i
would
recommend to all my colleagues seek them
out
find them and enjoy them because they
all these events
are a joy to behold and then we have
china
our fellow center of culture the city of
fuji in jiangxi province
i do not think the chain now during our
current chairman ever imagined
it would rack up over 60 000 air miles
and travel and receive commendation to
beijing wuhan and of course fujo
i hasten to add the trip to wuhan
was some 12 months before the pandemic
allegedly started
but one never knows the replica of
san wang which has also been a great
project
uh has obviously been delayed by the
panic pandemic
and i much look forward to either i or
or the current or future chairman
being able to take part in the opening
ceremony of san juan
at its completion sometime in the future
i know there was deep worry about the
opening of the peony pavilion
in um uh 18 months ago
but i do hope that has been completed
that people enjoy the pavilion for what
it is a gift to stratford
and it's very unique addition to our
cultural heritage
there is only one other penny pavilion
of this type outside china
and that is in perm the spiritual home
of the composer tchaikovsky
as we are the spiritual home of
shakespeare
i'm pleased to have been able to create
a lasting memorial during my time
the role of honor for the first world
war and the second world war
um was one i hope to produce as well
hopefully although got stopped by the
pandemic
there will be a rule of honor created
for all those who fell
uh in the second world war as well
i made one change to the counseling
agenda which i hope
people appreciate and that is the
opportunity
to have a summary of the agenda at the
front i think that very much helps
readers
um who don't wish to go through all the
papers and i'm not talking about my
colleagues members
but members of the public who just want
to see what is going on
and i hope that will continue and
finally
i very much hope sorry i've missed that
one
i very much hope that we will be able to
continue
the remembrance day commemorations that
i started on the centenary of
uh 1918 and that we will be able to
commemorate
the contribution of the fallen feminist
district in the services
country it's been a very interesting
two and a half years i have learnt
masses i have met the most interesting
people
and i hope i have been able to represent
the council to them
both here and of course overseas in the
manner that you expected me to do so two
and a half years ago
so thank you all it's been a bit of a
ride there've been ups and downs
in my case in a helicopter as well which
was unplanned
which of course did take me out for a
while um
and i'm just going to mention um
i was a little bit greedier than uh
councillor dixon
because in my first year i chose two
charities young minds and the brain
tumor trust
and i thought appropriate for my second
year to um
invite two separate charities and i i
chose the shakespeare
home carers and the for the series in
the air ambulance
now clearly my ability to fundraise in
the second year has been somewhat
challenged by a my helicopter ride but
be the
covered issues and i very much hope that
we will be able to have
some form of post um appointment
service led by nikki uh and also
a a an ex-chairman's lunch
which for which we'll be raising funds
um towards my two charities
for my most recent year i don't wish to
clash with anything the car current
chairman wishes to do as well
but i think it would be an opportunity
for us to join and join in to support
these modern charities
thank you ladies and gentlemen at which
point i'll sign off
and hand back the chairman it's been a
great two and a half years and thank you
for the privilege
thank you very much councillor kessel
and as we say the uh
the flowers and the gradual presented to
you slightly later
we now turn to item three on the agenda
the election of the vice chairman of
this council and i
seek nominations for the position of
vice chairman
i can see we've got a
nomination for kate rolfe to be the
councillor kate rolfe to be the vice
chairman
and a proposal for councillor edward
fitter to be
the vice chairman i have a secondary for
councillor fitter
i'm searching for
and council with complete council cleave
has seconded
uh councillor rolfe
so we have two nominations
uh okay so that means
we will have to have a secret ballot
which will be conducted by our
chief executive at the head of the paid
service
and uh you'll have a voting in the
in the chat between those two
nominations
thank you chairman so so chairman we
will now be sending the link by the chat
function to all the members of council
and you will be asked to indicate your
preference whether it's
councillor outfitter or council of rolfe
that will be a
that will be conducted better as i say
by by the secret ballot
as mentioned earlier if you are unable
to follow the
the link or and vote that way then i
would ask that you please
email me directly with either fitter
or councillor valve but we'll now have a
short break
whilst we conduct that ballot thank you
chairman i can confirm that we've
conducted the ballot
are we having a majority
so chairman do you have the you have the
result david
yeah thank you chairman so um following
the conduction of the ballot i can
confirm that councillor fitter
has been um elected as the vice chairman
of council
thank you thank you thank you david
i can now ask council of fitter to make
his declaration of acceptance
thank you chairman i edward fitter
having been elected to the office
of vice chairman of the council of the
district of stratford-on-haven
hereby declare that i take the office a
pun myself
and will duly and faithfully fulfill the
duties of it according to the best of my
judgment
and ability i undertake to be guided by
stratford-unhaven district council's
code of members conduct in the
performance of my functions in that
office
and i will now sign my declaration of
acceptance thank you
members may have noticed that uh i have
gained the chair of
the chain of office uh councillor fitter
will receive his uh vice chairman's uh
chain as such uh after the uh after the
proceedings have concluded this morning
but uh these
chains have all been sanitized as such
so they are
able to be used straight away thank you
we'll now move on to you might
think item 4 on the agenda however
item 4 will follow item
6. the next item is apologies for
absent and i asked invite the head of
the paid service to report the list of
apologies for absent
chairman thank you very much for that um
apologies have
been received from councillor victoria
alcock
and council kendall i just need to check
otherwise as per the world called
earlier we have a affordable counselors
however
could i just ask whether councillor
trevor harvey
is still on the call councillor harvey
i'm now on the call if you can hear me
thank you councillor harvey
thank you very much yeah so councillor
um
and councillor kendall thank you gemma
thank you david uh and welcome back uh
council for
harvey uh obviously those apologies have
been received and
it's uh on behalf of uh the members here
uh councillor orcot has some unhappy
family news
and uh her apologies are uh
understandable in the circumstances
uh now move on to item six
disclosures of interest i invite any
members to make any declarations of
interest
to the meeting
these should be shown in the in the chat
function please
can you change the screen
chairman yeah wait wait wait yes thank
you general that's just been resolved
thank you
do not see any uh declarations of
interest in the chat
so moving on now to item
four uh now obviously
a situation whereby i invite councillor
jefferson
as leader of the council to present his
report which will have been circulated
prior to this meeting
uh councillor jefferson thank you
chairman
um the statement uh the leader statement
is for noting by council
it contains everything it shouldn't
contain that's listed
um on the
the state the leader statement uh there
are two things i would just like to say
one is to welcome matt jennings as a new
member of cabinet
and the other thing is that the terms of
reference of the council
recovery advisory group are included
otherwise it is as it is german
and there are 17 pages of it
thank you thanks for jefferson and
members
certainly will have received that one
yesterday and indeed
it's a good long script
so the uh leaders statement is noted by
the council thank you chairman
moving now on to the planning committee
structure
item seven on the agenda and i again
invite councillor tony jefferson as
leader of the council to introduce this
item
thank you tony
uh just wanted to thank you chairman i
want to say that there's no doubt the
workload on both the council
and councillors has increased and even
allowing for the special situation of
covid
i think the workload is going gone up
i'd just like to highlight that with
some particular figures for
planning uh applications received in
april 2019 to march 2020
with 3871
uh in the first five months of the
current year
uh it's been 1616
and the forecast for the year is 3878.
interestingly enough that is almost as
high as the peak year of 2017
2018 when there were nearly 4 000.
uh committee determinations are
substantial
and the committee meets
twice a month so there is absolutely no
doubt
uh about the uh
increase in workload and planning so
what we have done is looked at the
evidence base which is listed
under three and we have proposed
uh the recommendations
on page one and
i would ask that the uh
council agree the recommendations on
page one
and i noticed that our a list of
questions
thank you tony yes you spotted the
questions as i was doing as well
so taking those in the order in which
we've received them
uh can i uh ask councillor junaid to
express her question please
yes my question is a point of
clarification
uh on a couple of aspects of the
proposal one is
um the the use of the word pool
i understand that that is strictly not
the way it is seen and the other aspect
i want clarification on
is how that uh will count towards
members attendance
um there is a risk under one um
interpretation of it is that um
counselors on their record
after the end of the year could see that
they're
uh they have not attended and that their
attendance record is not
not good uh could you could you please
clarify ex whether my understanding of
this is correct
could you uh tell me which paragraph you
referring to please counselor junior
um the pool is mentioned in point 7.1
i think the pool the pool is the number
is are the members of planning
committee that will be covered in
membership of committees when we come to
it later in the agenda
but i i also understand that anybody
that is not called to serve on the
planning committee from that
so-called pool um may not uh have a
record of attendance
by their name and this could look uh bad
on their
on their record at the end of the year i
would also want to make sure that
everybody was properly trained
uh if they are considered to be in in
that
in that pool because one of the things
we do need is
for very highly trained specialist uh
planning
district councillors i would agree with
you on the second point councillor
junior
and we will make sure that the first
point is covered as well
thank you tony can i now ask for
councillor bromwich to
put his question please yeah i'm
having looked down these proposals these
sit very
uncomfortably with me at the moment
especially in the light of the
discussions i had with the leader
some three or four weeks ago about
planning committees because
it doesn't address some fundamental
issues yes we're losing four councils
going down to one committee
yes we may well have better trained
counselors on
planning committees but i have great
concerns about the whole
process of planning applications and
it's no criticism
to the officers involved it's probably
more of a criticism
as us as councillors that actually a lot
of applications are going before
committees that
if officers and ward members if they
object to parish councils if they object
actually sat down and spoke properly a
lot of times a lot of these applications
wouldn't be coming through
and i think part of our solution is not
so much to just
lop off four councillors and reduce to
one committee
that we actually probably need seriously
to be looking at our whole
process this seems to me very
rushed at the moment nobody has looked
at the bigger
picture on those who have come up with
this idea and i think
seriously as counselors we need to get a
proper
procedures and process in place which
would lighten the workload to planning
committees
because i have certainly had the case in
the past two years
where i've had applications going before
committees which if people sat down
and talked various issues could have
been resolved and it would have never
gone
to planning committee and that is
actually relevant to four out of six
cases i've actually had on this
so at the moment i'm finding how to
justify
why the number is set at 12. i believe
actually we could have eight highly
skilled councils to actually do this if
we put the proper procedures and
processes
in place to be more engaging on this
part here and i think we would then be
lighting planning
committee workloads we'd be lightning
officer workloads we'd be saving
money at the moment this seems to be
just let's continue as we are but we'll
just lock a committee down
and reduce by four numbers and we'll try
and
also it implicates that we're there's
almost an attempt to try and stifle
debate so
lead i would seriously ask the question
should we not be looking at our whole
planning
process and engaging with counsellors
in general to how we want this process
to work
and to actually try and lighten up
workloads in general for everybody
and get a lot more engagement through
the whole system
i think uh councillor promised you there
is some interesting points
i think this paper that only seeks to
address the issue of the planning
committee
what you are obviously talking about is
much more around the whole
process of planning and i think
that probably needs to be picked up by
the chair of the planning committee
and the portfolio holder but i note the
points you made
i think they are very sensible and i
would hope
that the portfolio holder
and the chair of planning uh have been
listening
and will respond so thank you for your
question
uh thank you councillor broadmitry
councillor uh jefferson for that
response
can i now invite council adam to pose
his question please
thank you chairman thank you um
tony um it was in relation to the terms
of reference um
provided for um the proposal
um where a note is included
stating that um training
as may be prescribed by the council or
the committee from time to time
um i just don't think that this is the
most robust language to be included
as um when when considering the
requirements for planning
training uh adequate training as is
noted in the
uh in the report provided um is a
critical aspect of this
and so i would suggest that we improve
the language to
to ensure that this is um
more acutely aggressive potentially and
can be prescribed um with a bit more uh
vigor by the council
um or by the the committee itself
i i think in all honesty counselor adam
uh whatever the wording there is
absolutely no doubt about
it that the seriousness of planning
training
is really well known and well understood
thank you tony can i now invite
councillor richards to
speak please
thanks chairman councillor richards um
i i've got no issue with the principle
of what is being proposed um i have been
approached by a couple of my
uh parish councils and uh residents
within my
ward um and they've asked me to to raise
a concern that they have
um specifically that and this may be
isolated just to our ward but
both myself and counselor parry who
represents a number of
uh awards both at the district level and
the county council level
sit on planning there is concerns that
uh
where a an application from our ward
comes through
the two of us may have to step away from
the committee and that reduces the
number of councillors
that would then be hearing that that
application
and they have concerns over that they
would prefer to see obviously the
more cancers the better has there any
thought been put to that
um and if not or is it likely that there
would be some covering
in terms of um substitutes should that
case arise
thank you thank you um
i have to say councillor richards that
this hasn't been contin
uh considered but you raised a very
interesting point
uh i would have thought with uh 12
councils in the pool
uh if there were planning applications
coming through that affected
two members on the committee then there
are still enough councillors
and with two deputy chairs to actually
cover it
but nonetheless i think that's something
that we would actually need to keep
under review
thank you very much thank you gentlemen
can i now invite councillor pemberton to
speak
uh thank thank you chairman uh perhaps
just trying to pick up a number of the
uh points that have been raised so far
and and just to confirm for the
chief executive's benefit are i will be
seconding
uh this proposal um
it is um it has always been the case
that there is an encouragement
for applicants board members and
officers and indeed there is a duty on
our officers to engage with applicants
we already have a fairly robust scheme
of delegation
to remove as much as is as this council
feels
appropriate of the planning workload
it is difficult to see how we can
in other words in some respects
legislate to require further discussion
uh different parties to applications may
or may not engage so
i i'm struggling to see how uh we can
uh we can we can ensure further
engagement i think we've got good
robust processes as far as that is
concerned um
uh councillor richards raises a point
that you have two members who
potentially you know could be knocked
out
um we have a core of 12 with a quorum of
five
um and that should in general terms be
be sufficient uh for us to ensure
that um there is a sufficient member
a number of members as far as councillor
adam's point is concerned
uh the requirement for planning hours is
enshrined
um in the member development element
and the member development working group
makes recommendations to the council
there is an item further down on the
agenda
um as far as this overall proposal is
concerned
um the reality is that the workload is
such that
12 is the number we think we can map it
is the maximum number we think we can
actually
allow for given other roles to ensure
that we have
you know the highest quality of decision
making process
and uh you know this is uh a way forward
it is
absolutely the case that uh there are
challenges with the current system both
in terms of workload and managing
uh attendance so um really this is a
strong way uh
and an appropriate way forward um we've
demonstrated
we can address issues in a remote
fashion
uh and there would be uh certainly an
opportunity for this council to review
how this uh how this works uh
in in future and i would just uh
uh heartily commend all members to
support
uh the proposal thank you
thank you councillor pemberton i noticed
that uh councillor jr head
has initially indicated that she would
like to see a review by the the
over overview and scrutiny committee in
perhaps 12 months time but has also
requested to ask a question so if
councillor junet could cover those two
apps based and then i'll come back to
councillor crump who did actually uh as
it were press his keys before
uh councillor junior posed a second
question thank you councillor junaid
yes i would like to see this reviewed in
a year's time with the immune scrutiny
not only on the process of how it is
performed over the year
but because we are facing some major
reforms
in the government's consultations on
planning reform um the consultation
ending in october the 29th that will
significantly change the way that the
district council can
take part in in planning processes in
future
and and we do need to take that those
changes on board thank you
thank you councillor journal just
respond that i think
it is uh very obvious that things are
kept under almost continues for you
to ensure they are as effective as
possible but i know what you say about
the changes coming down the track
thank you councillor jefferson uh can i
now invite councillor crump to put
his question please thank you mr
chairman just
just a brief question for clarity really
um
paragraph 1.6 is to do with
consists of 12 suitably trained
counsellors
the quorum for a meeting will be five
councillors political balance will be
maintained
uh obviously attendance you know we've
got a pretty
uh robust number um can i just query
a point if the only five cancers
were available were all happened to be
conservative
um what would happen then
to be honest uh i think in all honesty
that the political balance being
maintained i think refers to the 12
people
on the in the planning on the planning
committee
not who's on each individual panel
okay yeah you say perhaps for next time
that could be just
like you know made clear i was asked
that by um one of my uh
thank you thank you councillor crump
um can i uh ask our chief
david buckland to speak because he's uh
expressed a wish to do so
chairman what whilst i don't want to
start for the debate i i just want to
reiterate the point that
reports on the council procedurals
members can speak once
on an item and i know um that there's
been requests
from from council to speak more one
thing title but i just want to remind
councillors
that unless there's an amendment and a
particular item has been debated you can
only speak once
on a particular item thank you
thank you david uh i see that uh
phil grafton has also expressed a
comment
i'll wish to speak so if i could invite
phil to also
uh express his opinion please thank you
oh thank you tony um it was in part
to repeat what david has just expressed
really that
um without wanting to stifle debate that
there is only one opportunity to speak
on emotion the other point
raised by um councillor crump
uh the political balance of course
relates to the people that appointed to
an individual committee rather than the
people who actually then
attend the meeting and just to pick up a
couple of other points that have been
raised by other
people yes the overall objective is to
reduce the workload of the planning
committee wherever possible
and of course we've tried that in the
past in terms of expanding
officer delegations but
we have few other weapons
to be able to reduce workload i do take
the point that
dialogue is also always useful to try to
reduce
the number of outstanding issues or or
not in fact
to require the matter to go to committee
but beyond that there's nothing that we
can actually legislate
for in terms of the um terms
of reference for the planning committee
in the reference to the loose wording of
the training
bit that that wording hasn't been
changed
it it it was already within the um
terms of reference but of course at item
nine on today's agenda
uh you will hear proposals and respect
of uh um training for members
including the planning committee so that
will be picked up then
thank you chairman
thank you phil i know the council of
june was
an amendment but i do also notice that
councillor bromish
rummage wishes to propose an amendment
so
over to you councillor bromwich
yes yes councillors i would like to
propose
the following amendment in regards to
this
which goes along these lines
council hereby recognizes the need
to try and reform the planning committee
and
speed up the process it will accept the
current proposals
with a review to take place in
six months time and also to incorporate
a review engaging all councillors and
officers to see what improvements if any
can be made to the planning process
to try and improve its efficiency
thank you councillor bromwich is there a
second for that amendment
counselor junaid i think has indicated
yes
council o'reilly i that he would second
that
amendment so on that basis uh before we
go to the
substantial indication regarding the uh
proposal by absolute jefferson uh we
will take the
amendment first is my understanding of
procedures
that's yes that's correct chairman
thank you phil
i can i ask is that by a simple
uh roll call please of the councils
chairman can i say that counselors have
indicated the wish to speak on the
amendment
um mr pemberton which is to speak thank
you on the amendment
thank you david cousin pemberton
thank you um the amendment uh seeks to
put in place a review
mechanism that has already been a
commitment
that there will be a review of the
process
um councillor junior quite rightly
highlights
that the government has proposals which
are out for consultation
that potentially could see sweeping and
significant changes to how
uh local planning authorities
deal with applications this amendment
seeks
a review within six after a six-month
period
um that could then find us in the
position where we then have to have a
further review
um not long after that accounting for
whatever comes out of
of government um the government review
and consultation
um there is a commitment to a review
i think i would i would urge members to
accept that there is a
review a commitment to a review and the
timing of the review does need to take
into account
um what's going to happen with central
government and we can't
we can't second guess that at this point
so
i would ask members just to take the
leaders
confirmation and the deputy leaders
confirmation there will be a review
and the timing of that review needs to
be uh
tied in with uh what is happening with
central government
otherwise we just end up uh doubling
upon work so on that basis
i won't support the amendment um but
reaffirm the commitment that there will
be an amendment
uh sorry i remember a review at an
appropriate time to tie in with
uh the outcome of the the government's
reforms
or proposed reforms i should say
thank you councillor pemberton uh i see
that uh councillor harris has requested
a repeat of the amendment so if
councilman bromwich can
please uh repeat his proposed amendment
please
yes repeating the amendment which went
along the following lines
is that yes we would be happy to adopt
the exist the proposals put before us
about the change in the planning
committee
subject to in six months time a
a review which would also incorporate
obviously mentioned about uh console
a consultation with councillors of
august political persuasions within the
council
and offers us to see how we can imple
improve the planning
process that's just a short version of
it
and to make sure obviously the committee
is actually functioning properly
thank you councillor i asked
phil grafton to please speak
thank you chairman i'm sort of getting
the sense here that this might be
turning into a friendly amendment
other than in terms of the timing of the
review
could counselor bromage just indicate
whether or not
he is amenable to a more flexible review
period than the six months that he's
indicating in which case if he is
then um the proposer and second of the
original motion might
i i suspect be willing to compromise
i think if we agree as past this
amendment that we will
over the next few months take into
account what i have suggested about
having
a fundamental look at our planning
process
and the ways we get engagement i don't
have an issue that if in six months time
then we have to extend
pending obviously we might know a bit
more about further
government proposals etc but i do think
as a matter of urgency we need to get
this process
underway and i think i would like that
commitment for this
the actions of the first part to
actually
get underway as soon as possible
thank you council of pemberton is saying
he lost me a bit there so i'll repeat it
for the benefit of councillor pemberton
i am happy
what's up for their for the process to
be extended if
need be however what i would like to
suggest is that we
get this review under underway as soon
as possible
to try engage counselors and officers
and see how we can try to improve the
process
i know council pemberton has said we do
lots already
but i'm sure if we all get our heads
together we can improve this a lot more
thank you guys perhaps it's the
situation whereby
uh the portfolio holder and the
chairman of the planning committees uh
liaison discuss and perhaps uh set up
some sort of early uh discussions with
uh all members of the council in order
that we can prove
get some flexibility as to a review date
but equally well
an understanding of the concerns of all
members
uh apologies to everybody but i noticed
that uh councillor curtis has requested
to ask a question
is it regarding the amendment or the uh
cons the initial
proposal i account for curtis it's
regarding the political
balance on the um chosen con
members from the pool um
i mean as political balance is important
in the pool
i can't see the rationale behind not
ensuring that political balance is
maintained
in those members of the pool that are
selected to be on the committee
either political balance is important
or it's not so i'm i'm i'm really rather
baffled by that as i think some of my
colleagues are as well
sorry we i think we need to find a
mechanism to ensure
that that group of members from the pool
to serve on the committee
also achieves that political balance
thank you
did i uh ask uh thank you councillor
curtis could i
ask phil grafton to perhaps uh speak to
that
suggestion comment uh
yeah i i i think there might be some
misunderstanding here if you look at
item eight on the agenda you've got the
political balance
issue coming up and i can just confirm
that
like all the all the other necessary
committees the
planning committee will be politically
balanced so there will be names
put forward um from
the conservative group and from the
liberal democrat group
which will make sure that the
composition of the committee
is politically balanced and that is a
legal requirement
separately from that there was a
discussion about
who actually attends the meeting and
this is where
we we have to just accept that some
people
are able to attend and some people
aren't and obviously
if if it happens to be uh
let's say four liberal democrats and two
conservatives turning up but then that's
that's acceptable um regardless of the
fact that the
committee itself the composition of
committee has to be politically balanced
thank you phil obviously planning is not
a political matter
it is a situation of training etc and
therefore although the committee needs
to be politically balanced
at the inception essentially when it
comes to a meeting a meeting does not
need to be
politically balanced and everybody
appreciates that i am sure
i think we now are in a position whereby
we can perhaps go
to uh a vote on that amendment
as the portfolio holder i would like to
speak
yes please
i found this amendment audacious i am
baffled
as to why uh members would think that we
would have to have a review within six
months
why on earth do uh members uh
really believe why we've had this change
in the first place it's because as
portfolio holder
i flagged up that the present system was
not
working as efficiently as possible so
therefore as portfolio
holder and as somebody who watches each
and every single planning meeting where
possible
you know if there is a problem with
anything happening there
then myself and the chair and the other
relevant uh cabinet members
get together and it will be amended
which will of course bring
to to to council to reflect on so i'm
finding
the nanny state of the review within six
months but it might even need to be
reviewed before that and and i'm
disappointed really
uh that you don't think that we are
capable of realizing if something
isn't working you know a great deal of
thoughts has gone into this
and uh frankly i think you know we are
trying to make this as fair as possible
so that the uh the responsibility of
being on planning committees and making
these
fundamental decisions for our residents
is shared quite equitably
amongst all of all councillors at
stratfor district
we have a great deal of work to do and
it must be done as efficiently as
possible
and of course if there are difficulties
or wrinkles
then you will be written too and we will
meet these will be discussed but to have
the
delay for an amendment vote i think is a
little patronizing as to our experience
and as to our um you know
the way in which we we manage ourselves
thank you
thank you councillor hoggins so we have
had a
amendment proposed we've had it formally
seconded and therefore we do need to put
that amendment
to uh the councillors for
their vote actually i think chairman
sorry
within the chat function i i have i do
see indicated that councillors
junior pemberton and jefferson would
all like to speak on the amendment
before we move to the vote
apologies jim
no problem david it's good to have a
team behind me thank you
i'll call on councillor junaid first mps
yeah thank you uh mine it was meant to
be a friendly amendment
uh a constructive amendment um
because it's always good practice to
review any new processes
and as they happen we have to keep an
eye on this new pro
pro process as it progresses and any
difficulties arising uh we need to
settle on a uh settle as it goes along
it is not just for the sake of for
people that are on the cabinet to do
that is for all cancers because this is
a democratic process we need to settle
on a review
at a sensible time because we do know
that the government's pro
government's proposals will mean a major
change to planning
and the democratic control and
democratic deficit uh
that that is in this council uh it um
you know as a result of that those
proposals so i do
find it um you know it is my job to make
sure
that uh as a leader of the opposition
that
i do ha ha you know have a hand in
making sure that things work
well i meant it is a friendly amendment
uh
and a constructive amendment and i hope
you will take it in that might that
that to mind thank you councillor junior
council of pemberton next please
thank thank you thank you chair um
the concept of a review uh i'm
comfortable with as a as a friendly
amendment i think the amendment
as put forward by councillor bromage
also seeks to widen the review
to you know look at our planning process
all over again
i wouldn't accept that as a friendly
amendment everybody agrees that we are
going to have to review this
at some point i think there is a
commitment to review it at some point
um and but that some point
has to take into account what's
happening as far as the government
reforms are concerned
unless we find that um you know it
you know it is not working on the ground
in which case uh the portfolio holder
for
for planning development will indeed
bring some some discussions further
forward and undoubtedly
would be having discussions across the
you know the wider membership so
um i'm just concerned that um
i'm happy with an amendment that um
talks about a review process at an
appropriate point
uh noting you know what's happening as
far as the the government reforms are
concerned
but i'm not happy that there's a
friendly amendment that a
seeks to widen the review to look at the
entire planning process and this whole
notion of
can we improve um dialogue because
that's entirely out of our control
we cannot force dialogue between
applicants officers and ward members um
we can encourage it but we you know we
can do no more than we already do
um so the principle of review i'm
absolutely fine with
i'm i'm struggling with being
shoehorned into a wider review and to
a a date that clearly would be in
advance of where we know the government
are going to be we we won't know where
the government's proposals are
uh you know by the time we get to circa
march
uh because because of the you know
they're unlikely to bring that forward
before then so
um i would uh i would happily accept a
a an in principle review um you know
subject to appropriate timing but other
than that i can't support the amendment
thank you thank you councillor pemberton
uh councillor jefferson is still in my
queue so
uh councillor jefferson please thank you
chairman
uh i would tend to agree with councillor
pemberton i think in terms of
reviewing the operation of the planning
committee specifically
uh i've already committed to doing that
i think a much wider review
is actually beyond the scope of this
paper and i certainly would not support
that amendment to this paper
thank you councillor jefferson i see
that
uh councillor kettle has requested to
speak
councillor kettle um
thank you mr chairman um may i suggest
as a compromise
that um if we focus on a review
of the existing changes that
counselor pemberton suggests a long stop
date
so that members can have the
assurance that this won't get
pushed into the long grass by other and
there will be many other issues coming
forward
that if we had a long stop date purely
to review
these changes what date
could councillor pemberton sort of
accept as a reasonable
um long stop uh which would
give that assurance
thank you councillor castle uh karen
darren pemberton council pemberton would
like to respond to that one please
i think i'd probably be uh thank you
chairman um
i think i think a backstop date is 12
months
uh only on the basis of not knowing
where we're going to be in terms of
timing from central government
um i think i don't think it should be
any longer than that
um but with the with the commitment that
you know
if if for some reason the government
decide that they you know they
um that you know that they decide to
change tax completely on their
on their reforms um um 12 months is is
the long stop um
we you know if if it's appropriate to
bring it forward
then happy to do so just just really
just looking for some flexibility so i
could live with a long stop back
uh back of 12 months but there is
absolutely the commitment to review once
we know
where things are at both set with
central government and how the new
process is working
in of itself angular council of
pemberton couldn't be more clearly
stated
so i have no more people
in expressing a desire to speak or ask a
question
in chat so i will now go to a vote
please on the amendment which was
appropriately proposed and secondly
thank you chairman and just remind
council so the amendment is to
not only review the uh process of the
planning pro um kind of
new connect committee but the entire
planning process within a
period of six months now when i when i
call your name
um if you could please just restate your
name and please
indicate whether you're voting for
against or you're saying for the
amendment as put
um councillor dixon
councillor dixon against
thank you counselor uh fitter
councillor fitter against thank you uh
councillor adam
councillor adam abstain thank you uh
councillor parker
against
are you on the line
okay thank you council constructor
councillor curtis
councillor curtis abstain thank you
councillor
councillor eden abstain thank you
fielding councillor fielding abstain
thank you for fitter oh sorry for me
that
is
council of foreman against thank you
counselor ian pretzley
councillor ian fragili abstain
counselor johnny crutchley councillor
jenny for actually
abstain thank you councillor harris
okay councillor harris come to speak uh
councillor harvey
council harvey against thank you
councillor hunter several thing
jefferson council jefferson against
thank you councillor jennings
jennings against thank
mills councilor mills against
thank you that's like o'donnell
councillor o'donnell against thank you
harry
councillor parry against
riley
councillor riley four thank you
rock cancel the rock abstain
thank you councillor rolf
abstain
against councillor richards
against upon me carefully richards
chairman that the amendment is lost
thank you
thank you david uh which we now move to
the substantial motion
that was initially proposed by
councillor jefferson in the chat
i noticed that councillor pemberton i
think seconded that
could we uh hear that please verbally
from uh councillor
henderson thank you chairman i confirmed
that i
second the main substantive proposal
thank you
thank you council of pemberton
okay chairman if there's no other
wishing to speak to would you wish me to
move straight to the vote
if that can go straight to the vote
please david yeah thank you chairman
okay so chairman i assume we'll walk but
uh just
to clarify with coach number three
recommendations as shown on the
agenda um and again i will be calling
out your name if you could please
indicate whether you're voting for or
against
abstaining for the recommendations as
has been julie
um seconded um chairman of council
councillor dixon
uh councillor dixon iv
[Applause]
uh by sherman councillor peter
councillor fitter
four okay counselor adam
council adam four thank you uh class of
parker
council joe parker
i'll come back to casper
thank you that's the point council of
fighting
for who comes to foreman
cancer thank you
cancer ian fragili thank you councillor
jenny freshly
that's the journey gradually for thank
you
councillor harris are you available to
respond
okay councillor harvey
thank you jefferson councillor jefferson
for the jennings
council mills for thank you castle
o'donnell
councillor donald four thank you
councillor parry
councillor parry four thank you council
of pemberton
cancer riley abstain okay
rock has now left the meeting that's
revolt council roll four
thank you council shempton councillor
shenton
four okay and councilor wally robbins
councillor wally hoggins four thank you
chairman that is carrie thank you
uh councillor barker four
pardon me counselor barclay didn't
return to you cast about before thank
you
it's still very bad thank you thank you
very much david
moving on now to agenda items eight
the political balance and membership of
the committees and i
invite councillor tony jefferson as
leader of the council to introduce this
item
uh thank you chairman uh the political
balance calculation for september 2020
has been circulated
this is a routine calculation
it's statistical uh i would assume there
are absolutely no problems with it
so um can i ask
council to accept the political balance
calculation
september 2020
you councillor jefferson can i ask for a
second to that proposal
i see in the chat that uh councillor
shenton has uh indicated
in second can i ask councillor shenton
to please speak
yes i quite clearly and quite simply
would say
that i second this proposal as it stands
thank you councillor shenton i see that
uh phil grafton has requested to speak
uh over to you please film uh there's no
vote required on this chairman
this is a this is a technical
calculation it's just for noting
recommendation two though is a matter
that might need
a vote depending upon how members feel
thank you
thank you phil
just to read out that the uh the
recommendation
uh two that uh mr grafton just referred
to there that the appointment of
councillors to committees as nominated
by the respective political leaders as
detailed and appendix to
to this report be approved have we
anybody to speak
against the recommendation to and at
appendix
uh nothing showing in the chat so we'll
take that as
noted agreed
and have been proposed and seconded it
is agreed without the need of a vote as
indicated by mr graham thank you
moving on now to
gender item 9 member training
requirements
and i invite councillor mark cargill as
chairman of the member development
working group
to introduce this item thank you very
much indeed chairman
first i'd like to say i'm delighted to
hear so much
discussion um over training and that all
our members
are aware of the need to continue our
excellent training program which is
the envy of many however what we're
going to be discussing very briefly here
is uh
just about the training of members to
committees and
i suppose i could say quite particularly
licensing
and planning the need for training
uh is obviously apparent a good training
and i do encourage members in spite of
what i'm just about to say
to attend as many training sessions as
is possible please
um right we are going through a torrid
time and
our training has taken a bit of a hit
recently as you can imagine uh
we are obviously exploring all options
and those
include as an example online and virtual
training sessions
but those have to be appropriate to the
needs
of our counselors attending those
particular committees
so our recent meeting held just this
week
was to discuss how we could actually
progress
our committee structure without falling
into a particular trap for example with
developers saying that our members
aren't suitably qualified or trained to
sit on committee
so the group discussed this and as is
indicated in the
paper to go to the leader it is
recommended that the leader should
recommend a council that training
requirements be reinstated on an amended
time frame
and i emphasize amended time frame
to allow all training hours acquired
between may 2019
and annual council in 2021 to be
included
in a member's overall total second point
being that the payment
of the 12th installment of the basic
allowance for those members
who do not meet the training objectives
be suspended until the annual general
meeting
in may 2021 i would ask again that
members please attend as many
as possible that is incumbent upon us to
provide those training sessions
thank you chairman thank you councillor
cargill
uh i've got two speakers uh councillor
jefferson initially and i see
council junaid would also like to speak
councillor jefferson first
thank you chairman i am more than happy
to recommend to council that training
the requirements be reinstated
on the time frame that's put down
i would also strongly echo councillor
cargill's
statement that training is really really
important
it enables counselors to do their job
properly
and i can only encourage all members
to take advantage of any training
opportunities
that are provided and it is most
unfortunate that
uh the kovid pandemic has actually
knocked on the head what was an
extremely well constructed training
program
so i would say i recommend the two
recommendations
one and two to counsel
thank you councillor jefferson uh
councillor junior please
uh yes howard endorsed that training is
essential but could i ask
also that those counsellors that attend
properly certificated training that's
provided by
people like the local government
association uh be considered as part of
the uh the training process
uh and that an easy pro easy way
of being able to get those certificates
through uh
to the council is agreed upon
thank you councillor junaid perhaps
councillor cargill would like to respond
certainly and absolutely cancer junior
um we are exploring that and discuss
that at our uh last meeting
for example there's a walk um
seminar on which we've agreed that can
count to members hours and also
some twin hatters who sit on county
those training hours can
also be included we are being flexible
and it's as simple as that we want to
try and encourage people to
[Music]
attend as many training sessions as as
possible
and i noticed that caroline has just
popped up on there said and yes
please email them to her and we will
certainly certainly consider them thank
you
thank you councillor cargill if nobody
else wishes to speak
if you do so please indicate in the chat
now
chairman can we just please have a a
proposing second for the
recommendations thank you david
i'm more than happy to propose chairman
thank you
thank you jefferson and can i ask i'll
secondly
councillor pemberton has been quick to
uh second
air so uh councillor pemberton if you
can vote for me do that for me please
thank you chair i confirmed that uh i
will second the
proposal thank you councillor pemberton
chairman if we can move therefore
straight to the vote
we could now please please go please
come here now please go straight to the
vote please david thank you
okay thank you children so chair uh
again once again
i'm asking councillors whether they're
voting for against or abstaining from
the recommendations
from the member development working
group um chairman of council councillor
dixon
councillor dixon for thank you vice
chairman councillor
councillor fitter for councillor adam
tony probably iv
council cargill four castle cleveland
council and cleve four castle crumb
council andy crump four okay curtis
council for curtis for multicultural
eden
for fielding
councillor fielding four thank you
fleming councillor fleming four
thank you mccoy councillor tick
for tesla foreman
councillor foreman for if you can select
ian gradually
cancer infatually four thank you
jenny gradually that's the journey
fledgling for
thank you kessler harris i think council
has indicated by a chat
that she agreed uh because harvey
castle trevor harvey
councillor harvey four thank you
councillor hench's heroine
to the united fall thank you against the
kettle
sorry council capital four i'll keep
into the mills
cancel mules for thank you
councillor o'donnell for tesla parry
councillor parry for pemberton
richards councillor richards iv vicky
castle o'reilly
council valley four
thank you david so that brings up
uh almost concludes uh the agenda for
today
essentially what i would uh remind
members
is that councillors please note that the
chairman and the vice chairman of the
various committees will be appointed
in meetings after this council meeting i
think we should perhaps have a
short i think perhaps the 10 minute
comfort break
and then resume and when we do resume
please remain linked to teams
and when voting occurs for the
individual committees
if anybody should be voting for chairman
who
are not uh on that committee but
uh vote because it appears in the chat
then
i should be looking towards a donation
for my chosen charity
so please come back in 10 minutes time
thank you
[Music]
can i ask members to be available within
one minute please
so
members the first uh committee meeting
which we have
is the audit and standards committee
and i call upon the chief executive head
of the paid service to report the names
of those councillors
appointed to serve on the committee for
2020
2021 and only those councillors which
are called
should partake as i've already briefly
mentioned
if anybody does so in error i should be
looking for a donation to my charity
thank you thank you chairman and this
begins the series of five
individual meetings so we're starting
with the audit and standards committee
as chemistry has indicated
this committee is only for those
councillors who are on that committee
that have just been approved by way of
the um
membership committees on the previous
agm so
i'm going to do an undertaker role call
and i'll ask whether the council has
completely confirmed that they can hear
and see the proceedings
uh councillor david curtis
council david curtis yes i can see and
here proceedings
uh councillor andy crump councillor andy
crump
i can confirm i can hear and see
proceedings
thank you councillor john fielding i can
hear it
and see proceedings thank you councillor
edward
councillorfitter i can confirm that i
can see and hear the proceedings
council before we tick i can hear
proceedings but i can't see any cameras
on
thank you uh it's sufficient that you
can hear the meeting so
i say that thank you that first
performance
yes i can see and hear the meeting thank
you fleming
cancer fleming i can hear the
proceedings but can't see any cameras
okay completely kessler harris
okay uh councillor kettle
councillor kettle i can see in here well
i can i can hear proceedings i can't see
them
i can see any other proceedings
okay i believe councilman rock is absent
and i haven't had a substitute nominated
um
so you can't talk to zachary thank think
chairman
thank you david
chairman you mute
uh have we received any apologies for
absence
no chairman are you david
we now turn to item three of that agenda
the appointment of the chairman
do i have a nomination for the chairman
of this committee
dixon can you hear me i would like to
nominate
councillor chris kettle
thank you very much uh we have a
nomination for the councillor kessle do
we have a seconder please
i see that uh
council of fitter has seconded cancel it
kettle councillor would you like to put
that vocally please
hello chairman please can i um second
counselor chris kettle for jen
thank you very much are there any other
nominations for
chairman
no other nominations are appearing in
chat so accordingly
i appoint councillor
councillor kettle a guipard and chris uh
to be the chairman
of audit and standards committee over to
you councillor kettle as the chairman of
that committee to take it to the next
stage thank you
thank you mr chairman i'll therefore
move on to point four of the agenda
which the appointment
of the vice chair of the committee for
the year 2021
um and i would like to nominate
councillor uh foreman um and i'd like a
second
for that councillor fitter and
councillor harris have both seconded uh
councillor foreman
uh councilmember you beat councillor
harris by amelia second would you like
to second
the aurora please thank you chairman i
would like to second
councillor joel forman for the vice
chairman
thank you do we have any other
nominations for the role of
vice chairman of audit standards
um well we have no other
um proposals
so therefore um we do not need a vote on
this one
congratulations can't perform when
you're elected
as chairman of audition standards and
um the first meeting of this committee
will be a week on monday the 21st of
september
and the agendas have actually been
circulated for that
thank you uh i'll close the meeting
thank you councillor kettle with the
closure of audit and standard we now
move to the
employment and appointments committee
and i call upon the chief executive head
of paid service to report the names of
those councils appointed to serve on the
committee for
2020 to 2021 only those councils called
upon are to partake
over to you david thank you chairman um
again if counselors could please repeat
their name and that they can hear and
see the proceedings when called
um counselor joe barker
counselor jay barth are you there
okay i'll come back in the second
councillor joe cleve
yeah thank you council until cleve okay
then he comes before take
i can hear proceedings thank you
yes i can see the proceed i can hear the
proceedings thank you
ian frankly
that's not even freshly i think you're
muted
okay that comes to trevor harvey
cancer harvey can see in here
pemberton council of pemberton i can see
and hear the proceedings
council jefferson
that's the tony jefferson in the
proceedings
like it is catholic there please yes i
can hear the proceedings
thank you and counselor ian frenchly
i can hear the proceedings
thank you um councillor alcott
is is absolutely chairman and apologies
for goodness sake thank you
thank you david all right substitute
are there any substitutes not named for
uh council all clock
i haven't been advised on any
substitution
i know the nominated substitutes are
council specific
and councillor rolfe uh i i there are
those available to
uh substitute for councillor
olcock
yes i'm available i can do that as
council or pertage
here thank you councillor by together
right you've been you're acting as a
substitute in this meeting
yes thank you
so having uh
established that i think we can move to
the item three of that
agenda the appointment of its chairman
and i
ask for nominations for the chairman of
this committee
in the chat i can see council of
pemberton has
nominated councillor jefferson uh would
you like to uh
vocally speak without one councillor
pemberton please
thank you chair i nominate councillor
jefferson
as the chair of the employment committee
thank you councillor pemberton uh the
second that i see in the chat
is indicated as councillor harvey
councillor harvey would you like to
confirm that in vocally please
delighted to second mr chairman
thank you councillor harvey are there
any other nominations for the chair of
this committee
i see nothing appearing in the chat i
accordingly appoint
councillor jefferson to be
of this employment and appointments
committee
over to you tony thank you chairman
uh could i ask for nominations for vice
chairman of the committee
and i propose councillor pemberton
i see councillor harvey you've seconded
that can you just confirm that
verbally please equally delighted to
second
thank you councillor harvey are there
any other nominations
i'll take that as a no in that case
councillor pemberton is vice chairman
of employment and appointments the next
meeting of employment
appointments is scheduled to take place
on tuesday the 24th of november
and with that i close the meeting
thank you to tony moving now on to
the overview so chairman
before we move on to the um the next
meeting of the open security committee
could i please ask
the monitoring officer to advise in
relation to comments
being made in the chat by council jackie
harris councillor harris indicated that
she
seconded um the nomination for the
chairmanship of the audience standards
committee
and that was overlooked um
phil phil can you please advise i
apologize to councillor harris
um yes um so
who who was she seconding then
okay chairman this goes back to the
appointment of the
chris kettle as chairman of the audit
and standards committee
and it was recorded that um
it was seconded by somebody else who i
couldn't go now
and i think this book noted that she was
the seconder yeah
i think this is better sorted off
offline to be honest david rather than
right here in
while we're sorting out some of the
committees okay
well we'll we'll deal with that at that
point i saw each other
thank you david for that assistance
there
so if we now move through on to the
committee overview and scrutiny
committee please
and again i call upon the chief
executive federal paid service to report
the names of those councils appointed to
serve on this committee for 2020 2021
only those councils called upon are to
partake
thank you chairman again i'm do the role
call for the
membership of the um or oh sorry
overland
scrutiny committee uh councillor crumb
present and can hear proceedings
thank you councillor curtis yes
president can
hear proceedings thank you thank you
john fielding
councillor john fielding can hear the
proceedings
thank you edward councillor
i can see and hear the proceedings
uh counselor foreman i can hear the
proceedings
thank you tesla ian frenchly uh cancer
in factually i can hear and see the
proceedings thank you councillor susan
jones
councillor susan janet i can hear the
meeting
thank you chris kettle counselor chris
kettle i can hear the proceedings
thank you chris mills
chris mills i can hear and see all the
proceedings thank you
thank you councillor pena o'donnell
i can see and hear the proceedings thank
you thank you
for taking off counselor kate rolfe
i can hear proceedings
thank you thank you
thank you david are there any apologies
for absence
no no apologies chairman
item three the appointment of the
chairman do i have a nomination for the
chairman
of the overview and scrutiny committee
please
in the chat i say councillor june ed has
proposed councillor david curtis
uh councillor juned would you like to
verbally uh propose that one please
yes i would like to propose uh david
curtis as
chairman of overview scrutiny noting
that this is common practice
in most councils across the country that
the chair is
from the opposition major opposition
group thank you
thank you councillor junaid uh can i see
a second for that i think council of
rolfes please
i second that casserole
thank you council rolfe i can see that
we have another nomination
uh as well in respect of councillor
kettle i think has proposed that
our council oh donald but
perhaps you could speak to that
yeah so the kettle are you there are you
wishing to propose a chairman for this
overview and scrutiny confirm i i
propose
council o'donnell for chairman of
overview i apologize mr chairman
thank you uh i can see that uh
we have a second uh in uh edward
councillor
has seconded council o'donnell can you
please confirm that
yes uh please may i second uh councillor
penny and o'donnell for the role of
chairman
thank you councilor as we have two
nominations both proposed and seconded
we need to go to a secret ballot
in respect of this one so there will be
a question posed in the chat
abstention alternative if you don't want
either of those people
thank you and chairman if i could
reiterate members of council please
only the members of the overview and
scrutiny committee can vote on this
particular item
thank you
okay
david i can't see the link sorry sorry
david chris mills i can't see the link
for the uh
voting on this okay chris
it should be in the um the chat function
have you opened the check function
chairman it's a chat from olivia
at 113
it comes if if you can't see that
you can't see it okay council mills if
you fancy it could i please ask that you
just email me
directly um the that you're
the first candidate for the the
chairmanship of the overview and
scripting committee please
oh crumbs
just open me chris sorry
have you got the check function open at
the moment have you
i've got it open and can you see the
post from olivia quinn at
13 13.
this is showing the chair of verisc
olivia sent it directly to yourself now
as well that's the most
now now i just give a hint it's actually
the chat function on the left hand side
of the
screen not the chat function which is
within the video screen
can i just ask whether you've been
successful yeah we have votes from
all of the members of the committee have
you been able to email us yet
because
chairman i i i can report that
councilman seems to have left the
meeting and
the vote would be the result of the vote
would be the same
with or or without the vote from
councillor mills
and therefore i believe i can declare
that
um councillor o'donnell has been elected
as chairman of the committee
thank you david we'll miss councillor
mills if he has disappeared but
uh certainly if the numbers would not be
any different if uh councillor mills had
been able to
exercise a vote then i declare
councillor o'donnell
the chairman of the overview and
scrutiny committee
and asked councillor o'donnell to take
item 4 of that agenda thank you
thank you chair i would like to
propose counselor junard as vice chair
of overview and
scrutiny do we have any other could i
get a seconder for that please
i see because indicated in the chat that
he would like to
second councillor junaid as the vice
chair position
uh can councillor curtis please confirm
that vocally thank you
yes thank you uh councillor curtis i
would like to
second council of juniors vice chair of
overview and scrutiny
thank you then do we need to check if
there are any other proposals chair
i take it that counselor do not
congratulations you are now vice chair
of the
immune scrutiny committee look forward
to working with you
and just to advise at the next meeting
of overview scrutiny
is on wednesday the 30th of september
an agenda and timing will be forwarded
to you and now close the meeting
thank you thank you
o'donnell i drove i dropped into the uh
the big
uh pot that i shouldn't have created
apologies start taking over
your agenda and i shall have to put some
money in the pot myself
in respect of my uh my walk which i will
indeed do so
we'll now move on to the planning
committee and i
call upon the chief executive head of
the paid service to report the names of
those councils appointed to serve on the
committee for 2020 2021
only those councils called upon our
two-part take thank you
thank you chairman again i will call out
the names of the councillors who from
taking this meeting if you could please
repeat your name and confirm that you
can hear and see the meeting
councilman lewis adam councillor adam i
can see and hear the proceedings maybe
newcastle trump
yes curtis i can see into your
proceedings thank you pastor tony dixon
uh counselor tony dixon i can see and
here thank you
eden
councillor and i can see in here
proceedings yeah
pastor bill fleming cancer bill fleming
i can hear all proceedings
thank you uh councillor hensha seraphine
cancer and your surfing i can hear the
proceedings
thank you pastor matt jennings counselor
journalings i can hear and see
all proceedings thank you uh counselor
danny kendall is absent
um councillor chris mills
suggest me also i can hear and see all
proceedings thank you
thank you i believe councillor parry has
also leave the meeting left meeting
pastor perry
and councillor richards councillor
richards i can see in here proceedings
thank you thank you
uh can i ask if there's any apologies of
answers i suspect
there are none chairman i haven't
received any formal apologies
um no but but as as we wrote advice
earlier councillor paris
had to to leave the meeting and we had
already
received apologies for counselor kendall
so yeah sorry councillor kendall and
casper parody
thank you david
[Applause]
the next item is to call for nominations
for the chairman of this committee and
as i am a member of this committee
i would like to propose councillor
richards to be the chair of this
planning committee is there a second of
these
thank you councillor jennings i can see
that uh you have seconded that proposal
could i ask you to
put that in uh verbally please
councillor jennings i would like to
second councillor richards for chair
thank you councillor i'll now hand over
to
are there any other nominations please
no other nominations appearing in the
chat i therefore declare that
uh councillor richards is the chairman
of the
planning committee over to you
councillor richards thank you
thank you casa dixon uh thank you
members for your vote of confidence i
saw uh cancer fleming also proposed me
but sadly he was beaten by uh
councillor dixon um we do now need to
appoint uh two vice chairman
um uh which is contrary to the uh point
four of your agenda it is two rather
than one
um i would like to start by proposing uh
councillor danny kendall and
councillor bill fleming could i please
have seconders for
councillor kendall first of all
you can see councillor jennings has
seconded that and a second different
council of fleming as well please
cancel the fielding regrettably you are
not part of this committee so i'm afraid
i can't take that second thing
but you will be required to pay into the
charity party
sorry councillor adam thank you very
much i can see councillor jennings the
second is as well so there's two seconds
whether closing a second are there any
other nominations for vice chairman
i will take that as a no in that case um
congratulations councillor kendall and
council fleming you are duly elected as
vice chairman
our first meeting proper will be on the
23rd of september i declare this meeting
closed thank you very much
thank you councillor richard moving on
to our
final committee which is the regulatory
committee
and again i call upon the chief
executive head of the paid service to
report the names of those councils
appointed to serve on the committee for
twenty twenty twenty fifth one
only those councillors called upon are
to partake
thank you chairman um again if you could
just repeat your name when i
call it and that you can hear and see
the the proceedings please uh councillor
tony bromwich
yes councillor tony promised here and
can hear and see everything
thank you councillor david curtis yes
council david curtis can soon hear
everything thank you
thank you councillor edward fitter
councillor edward fitter i can see and
hear the proceedings
thank you john fielding councillor john
fielding i can hear the proceedings
thank you council bill fleming
councillor bill fleming i can hear the
proceedings
thank you uh councillor jenny crossley
uh i can hit here and see the
proceedings
thank you thank you christopher mills
council chris mills i can hear and see
all proceedings thank you
thank you dr peter richards
councillor richards i can see and hear
all proceedings
professor john riley council john marley
i can see and hear the proceedings
thanks thank you
councillor rock has left the meeting
councillor ian shenton
cancer ian shenton i can see and hear
the proceedings
thank you
note that there are substitutes
available i believe
there are i haven't been advised of any
substitutes we have apologies from
customer marginal rock
my understanding is that councillor
peter
henshaw elephant is a substitute for
this meeting
of the regulatory committee and if
available can uh join in please
okay fine by me just therapy
thank you thank you gentlemen
thank you david and thank you uh
councillor henshaw telephone
now i asked for nominations for the
chairmanship of the
regulatory committee
chair i have indicated in the chat but i
will do it formally uh over the voice
um i have great pleasure in uh proposing
councillor chris mills as chair of the
regulatory committee
senator councillor richards and i can
see that councillor shenton has
seconded i think uh can i seek
asks councillor shenton to speak please
yes of course i'm quite happy to second
the
nomination of chris mills
thank you councillor shenton
are there any other nominations for the
chairmanship
i see no other nominations for
chairmanship accordingly
councillor mills to be the chair of
regulatory
council mills i hand over to you for
items four of your agenda
thank you very much mr chairman um
i'd like to do i have any nominations
for um
vice chairman of the committee um
actually i'd like to nominate
um edward fitter as vice chairman and
is there a seconder
that's that's ian shanton yes
yes i'm quite happy again cancer in
shenzhen quite happy to
second um
thank you very much and are there any
other nominations
no
thank you no more nominations from that
thank you
sorry sorry councillor is the point of
this question
yes
i'll ask that yes sorry of course yes
so we nominate um edward fitter as
uh vice chairman of the regulatory
committee thank you
council mills would you like to continue
with the licensing panel please
right um the licensing panel um
um do i have um
nominations for the chairman of the
licensing panel please
i think there are three chairmen to
reappoint there are
as i understand it can be done on block
mr chairman
not not individually
sorry the names have been put forward
are councillor fleming
edward fitter and myself
no chairman so
the intrinsic is proposing councillor
mills fitter and fielding i see no other
proposals
yeah at the moment so can we have a
proposal for that
chrysler shenton could you confirm that
please yes i
quite quite happily confirm that i
propose cancer mills fitter and fielding
as chairman of licensing
and uh is there a seconder please
thank you bill
general are there any other nominations
any other nominations
no
no other nominations no thank you in
that case then
um the uh the next meeting for the
regulator committee will
um be on friday the 13th of november
and um i end this meeting thank you
thank you councillor mills and i think
that concludes today's business
so thank you to everybody who's partake
in this uh
technical um extravaganza we've had the
annual meeting we've had the various
committees afterwards we've not all had
to stand up and sit down stand up and
sit down as the usual
uh rigmarole of uh we we go through
nevertheless
this has been uh a meeting with a
difference
and certainly my first one and uh
hopefully the rest will
uh be a little smoother from my
perspective um
not that's no comment on on any members
it's more comment on myself
thank you very much indeed gentlemen and
ladies
thank you
many thanks